bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
cette ut week-end votre magazine dédié
aux sorties et vos loisirs
au sommaire les écuyers de bartabas
remonte en selle pour proposer une
nouvelle version de leur spectacle la
voie de l'écuyer et photographier les
animaux à travers le monde c'est ce qui
attire filipe bole se photographier
yvelinois nous parlera de son travail et
de sa passion mais tout d'abord on va
s'intéresser à la 10e édition de la
semaine femmes du monde de la commune de
magny les hameaux
cette année le thème ce sont les pleurs
les peuples nomades de nombreux ateliers
des expositions des rencontres sont
proposées sont proposés et pour en
parler thérèse même au jour vous êtes
adjointe au maire à la communication la
démocratie locale et katherine legge
aura vous vous êtes comédienne et
metteur en scène et vous êtes notamment
charge d'une rencontre le jeudi 10 mars
dont il parlait un peu plus précisément
tout à l'heure tu es la semaine déjà
pourquoi proposer deux semaines
d'animations autour de la femme
eh bien écoutez en lien donc avec la
journée de la femme prévue le 8 mars à
manier la moe et en fonction de la
politique sociale et culturelle nous
avons voulu développer un peu enfin
voilà augmenter un peu c'est ce regard
sur les femmes et sortir de celui voilà
seuls 10 mars verront c'est tellement
peu c'est donc quinze jours pour nous ça
nous semblait important de pouvoir
partager
et puis surtout aller vers les femmes du
monde et ne pas se concentrer simplement
sur la femme un enfant de naître
déjà qu'on se connaît tous exactement et
cette année ce sont les peuples nomades
qui ont un rythme de vie un peu
particulier vous souhaitiez de mettre en
avant si tout à fait alors ça c'est dans
le cadre la démocratie participative
nous avons chaque année notre conseil de
centre qui travaillent sur les sujets de
l'année suivante et donc on choisit ce
peuple nomade un ce peuple himba qui ont
des grosses difficultés enfin dans leur
quotidien voilà une date qu'on a pu
découvrir il ya quelques années dans une
une émission sur bandes sionistes
excuses étaient les héros de rendez vous
en terre inconnue frédéric lopez est une
réelle roumain ilie à une exposition qui
dure jusqu'au 13 mars à rümikon la
présenter en typo cette exposition mais
écoutez vous pourrez la découvrir enfin
j'invite tout le monde tous les mails
coloniale à découvrir à l'estaminet donc
à partir du lundi 29 février
voilà donc là vous voyez un peu tout le
tout le quotidien de cette pièce de son
peuple
sachant que c'était quand même un peuple
matriarcale qui est quand même non
négligeable et puis quand même assez
révélateur et jeux ea j'habite vraiment
tout le monde à venir lire et découvrir
cette population très riche aussi on
pourra y voir quoi des photos des photos
du texte leurs rituels de mariage les
transmission de génération en génération
comment y vivent ce qu'ils mangent donc
elle a été réalisée par nolan qui était
spécialiste de ce peuple là en
particulier d'accord donc il est aussi
des ateliers d'éveil musical des
percussions des débats mais vous faisait
quel âge c'est pour les enfants les
adultes c'est alors tous les ateliers
sont ouverts à toutes les tranches d'âge
donc il y aura beaucoup pour les enfants
mais nous nous voulons que les parents
participent donc nous avons mis au point
un prix symbolique donc de 2 euros pour
certains ateliers et la gratuité pour
les parents justement pour les
encourager à venir participer et puis
que ça soit un peu intergénérationnel
participent à des activités en famille
c'est très important
et la voilà beaucoup d'originalité dans
les ateliers il va y avoir
l'éveil musical vous allez avoir les
ateliers de percussions les tissages
vous allez avoir la journée du 5 mars où
il y aura
l'installation d'une yourte kate une
tante qui une tente de mongolie lors
l'habitation en mongolie
cette tente donc ça sera installée de 10
heures à 12 heures devant le public
donc voilà les gens pourront apprendre
et voir un peu comment s'installe c'est
sold out et ben oui oui tout à fait
exactement donc voilà il faut que ce
soit quelque chose de simple et facile
pour pouvoir se déplacer
ensuite il y aura des cours de
calligraphie et puis alors de la danse
de des massages vraie ouverture où
exactement
vous verrez aussi parce que vous mettez
c'est pour faire participer les manu
quoi et vous les mettez aussi en avant
catherine elle fait partie de ce rendez
vous là le 10 mars
qu'est-ce qui se passe alors je précise
tout de suite c'est le 10 mars à 14
heures parce que sur le programme qui
est en ligne cette annonce est à 19
heures donc je rectifie l'horaire j'en
profite c'est de 14 heures à 16 heures
le 10 mars l estaminet donc en fait
c'est la ville et le centre social qui
m'ont demandé de mettre en scène ces
femmes du monde mais il y a deux hommes
également qui vont participer
en fait les participants sont dans un
atelier sociolinguistique qui est
encadrée par des bénévoles que je salue
d'ailleurs puisqu'ils font un travail
magnifique et donc qui voilà qui les
entraîne à apprendre le français à
l'écrire à le dire alors alizés voilà et
moi donc ils ont écrit des petits textes
en collaboration avec leurs intervenants
et ses petits textes je les mets en
scène
je les aide donc à se présenter je pense
que pour eux c'est extraordinaire parce
qu'effectivement c'est une façon tout
d'un coup d'être en présence et un petit
défi à relever d'articuler le français
de le jouer de le parler fort
voilà j'ai fait une petite scénographie
pour qu'ils soient tous mis en valeur
c'est sam allen de mettre en avant c'est
ce qui se fait à manille les gens qui
vivent
les gens qui travaillent les
associations c'est très important pour
nous c'est ce qu'ont fait régulièrement
justement c'est quand même le coeur de
tous et ils sont les habitants de la
commune
c'était de longues répétitions comment
ça s'est passé c'est sur un temps très
court
en fait elles viennent ils viennent il
faut que je m'habitue à dire ça ils
viennent le jeudi de 14 heures à 16
heures donc moi je suis venu répéter
avec eux sur leurs horaires et il répète
sans moi aussi un petit peu avec leurs
intervenants
j'ai proposé un cadre une mise en scène
est donc à l'intérieur de ça on va
retravailler la 2 3 mars avant la
prochaine donc voilà l'ultime jour je
vais je vais amener de la musique aussi
donc il ya des petites danses que
j'aimerais intégrer que nous allons
régler au jeudi
voilà c'est toute une aventure
donc les personnes viennent du maroc de
l'algérie du niger du vietnam du
portugal d'euros rien au monde
voilà et donc femmes femmes du monde va
enfin parce qu'elles sont quand même
essentiellement c'est ce sont des
pharmas voilà ils sont elles vont
pouvoir aussi faire partager peut-être
leur expérience ce qu'elle des pays d'où
elles viennent
j'espère oui oui j'espère mais l'a pour
l'instant les petites saynètes sont pour
les peuples nomades on a travaillé sur
le sahara donc les peuple touareg et
puis une deuxième partie sur les peuples
nenets voilà je peux plus du nord qui se
déplace également donc le chaud et le
froid le chaud et le froid puis c'est là
je les ai d'ailleurs c'est la dixième
édition
c'est un beau succès plein d'exemples
vouloir une nouvelle récente nous
espérons pouvoir poursuivre les années
suivantes
on parlait du prix tout à l'heure alors
oui pour des questions pratiques il faut
s'inscrire il ya des choses qui sont
déjà complètes oui alors les ateliers
les ateliers de tissage sont déjà
complets en début de semaine prochaine
donc vraiment j'invite les gens à aller
s'inscrire au centre social dont je
communique le numéro de téléphone le 0 à
30 52 22 00
voilà il reste quelques places dans tous
les ateliers et j'insiste sur la journée
du 8 mars où il ya donc là le ciné débat
donc la projection du film femmes de roc
vraiment un très beau documentaire
suivie d'un débat
je pense que ce sera très intéressant
justement de pouvoir échanger partager
ils se rencontrent de l'émancipation de
la femme qui n'est pas toujours facile
dans certains pays merci à toutes les
deux être venu en plein temps sans nous
en parler
le souhaiteraient y avait terminé
remercier tous les partenaires qui nous
aident à travailler sur ce projet c'a
vraiment sans eux
voilà on aurait du mal donc tous
ensemble on y arrive et pour aller à la
rencontre de ses partenaires
la programmation est à retrouver sur le
site de la commune je le rappelle c'est
du 29 février au 13 mars
si vous y allez les peuples nomades
n'auront plus de secret pour vous alors
on change complètement sujet puisqu'on
part à l'académie équestre de versailles
elle débute sa saison avec un nouveau
spectacle les écuyers de bartabas
remonte en selle dans le manège de la
grande écurie du château royal
il propose un nouvel opus du spectacle
la voie de l'écuyer
cette année il ya de l'attelage furane
parfait nous en donne un aperçu
ils ont repris en musique le chemin du
manège les huit écuyers et leurs chevaux
à nouveau réunis dans un ballet
envoûtant et chorégraphié par bartabas
le spectacle la voie de l'écuyer existe
depuis 2003 mais chaque année il
s'enrichit au gré des envies et des
expériences de la compagnie
la plage c'est la grande nouveauté de
cette saison une discipline nouvelle
pour les chevaux et pour les écuyers il
leur a fallu un nom pour mettre ce
tableau en place il ya plus de
mouvements possibles les chevaux une
fois adressé peuvent piaf et pierre ont
été sous la voiture et tourner autour de
son axe que peuvent pas faire ai-je pu
normalement l'attelage donc entre la
construction des voitures le
l'adaptation du matériel qu'on a fait
ici sur place après un petit peu de
temps plus le dressage des chevaux qui
est la base d'attaché pas une discipline
particulière les figures de dressage
traditionnels comme le carrousel
lusitaniens sont toujours présentes
elle se mêle à d'autres disciplines
comme les scream le kyodo le tir à l'arc
japonais ou encore le champ il ya eu pas
mal d'évolutions dans les chorégraphies
ce soit pour le travail aux longues
rênes le carrousel le trio après la
représentation les spectateurs se
pressent dans les écuries amateurs de
chevaux novices ils viennent parfois de
très loin pour voir le travail de
bartabas g réserver mes billets sur
tours elle charrie vie ici et souzy mans
pour ça alors si le spectacle vous tente
les écuyers leurs montures offre chaque
week-end de représentation le samedi à
18h ou le dimanche à 15 heures
et
vous faites peut-être partie de ceux qui
lorsqu'ils voyagent aime faire de la
photo philibeaux lui en a fait un art il
les photographie vinoy et capturent les
moments de vie des animaux à travers le
monde et nous a rejoint quant à thomas
au jour et à chaque fois que nous faire
une photo vous êtes là claude bonjour je
le rappelle vous êtes le président de
l'union régionale photographique et
cette semaine de france de france et
cette semaine on a décidé donc de parler
du coût du travail de silly boy pourquoi
les gouttes et philippe donc est un
photographe que je connais depuis un
certain temps c'est un photographe qui
est un photographe animalier donc
philippe je sais à une très très grande
passion pour la photo animalière il
il a ce côté aussi environnemental s'ils
voulaient donc il parle de aussi des
destructions que peuvent faire l'homme à
travers cibler l'utilisation de tout ce
que tout ce que nous avons aujourd'hui
et c'est pour ce fait que s'ils
voulaient jeu on l'a invitée sur le
plateau qui viennent nous parler sur les
de la photo animalière et surtout
comment ils la pratiquent
et justement alors ses épaules comment
qu'est ce qui vous attire c'est le
mouvement l'animal en lui même les
animaux sont il faut d'abord dans un
premier temps déjà bien connaître le
terrain savoir où en est qu'on veut à
connaître le comportement des animaux
avant des photographies est essentielle
à pour leur comportement et aussi pour
la nature ces terres ne pas les déranger
quand on connait pas trop on peut
effectivement déranger les animaux et
c'est pas le but prendre des photos
c'est pas on tout n'est pas permis il
faut quoi il faut beaucoup de patience
il faut de la patience pour la
connaissance du terrain et puis surtout
ne pas déranger parce que les animaux
si on les dérange on les reverra plus
même dans un affût faut être très très
prudent se faire très discret et surtout
ce que je dis souvent c'est par la photo
à tout prix c'est à dire que la photo
elle et réalisa quand on est dans l'est
on est
tout tout tout se passe bien à quoi
qu'on va pas déranger que attention vous
parlez de préparation dans quel sens il
vous renseigner auprès de personnes vous
allez d'abord faire des repérages qui
s'assombrissent tout à fait tout à fait
essentiel de repérage
tout à fait on peut pas en bilbo devons
ça arrive quelques fois que vos tombes
s'ils ont reçu j'aime et bien connaître
le terrain sa voix il se fait à
conseiller effectivement il ya des fois
il ya des sorties qui sont faites par
les là il peut enfin des protections et
là on peut déjà commencer à bon discuter
avec les gens sur le terrain voir est
rarement du hasard la photographie
animalière ça marche que pour l'animal
la préparation je pense que ça marche
aussi pour bien d'autres choses cibler
ce que disait des gens comme willy ronis
qui aimons en 2009 il disait que quand
on quitte un photographe humaniste
ciblés ils disent eh bien on se met dans
on découvre on est en droit avec une
belle lumière va on se met devant et on
attend qu'il se passe quelque chose
si vous voulez je crois qu'aujourd'hui
malheureusement les photographes
on sait on est dans l'immédiateté c'est
à dire que on appuie sur le bouton on
fait de la photo ce que j'appelle
spontanée et parfois un peu une photo un
petit peu plus réfléchi serait
intéressant mais je voudrais quand même
revenir si vous voulez sur le travail de
philippe que je vois évoluer quand même
depuis pas mal de temps et je crois
qu'il a des maîtres si vous voulez dans
la matière vincent munier je crois qu'on
peut le site et il ya aussi kyriakos que
je pense qu'un jour on pourra accueillir
sur ce plateau c'est bien sûr que si
vous avez vous pensez que c'est
intéressant mais qui vont donner si vous
voulez parce que photographier un animal
c'est bien mais lui donner de l'émotion
si vous voulez parce que les amis des
animaux ont aussi des émotions et c'est
essayer si vous voulez de prendre cette
émotion petit filet peux nous en parler
mieux que moi
prix exact mais c'est vrai il donc la
photographie animalière com
le pratique vincent munier ou kyriakos
que je connais très bien
ils ont ils ont mis une touche un petit
peu artistique dans leurs photos alors
c'est intéressant bien sûr parce que
c'est ça permet à de plus grand nombre
de personnes de les intéresser à la
nature est ce que la nature non
seulement c'est intéressant sur deux
choses c'est que il faut absolument la
protéger et le fait d'avoir des
magnifiques photos ça induit le respect
de la nature dévoile reste tout à fait
et le fait de la photo artistique cela
peut toucher un plus grand nombre de
personnes que ceux qui sont vraiment
uniquement nature c'est vrai comme dit
donc claude
la photo animalière ça peut être du
reportage et puis on peut aussi affiner
la photo pour la rendre plus plus
artistique et ça c'est vraiment des
photographes qui ont réussi ça sent il
vous en serez vraiment des réponses
ordina claude parler aussi de l'émotion
il ya une photo qu'on envoyait j'ai
trouvé absolument magnifique c'est cet
ours polaires excès passés est ce que
vous pouvez m'en parler un petit peu de
cette photo a été pris au sol barde au
mois de juin
donc c'est un mois un peu pénible pour
les ours surtout quand ce qu'ils ont en
dessous du 80ème parallèle parce qu'il
ya un manque de glace qui est évidente
et pour la chasse pour chasser l'ours a
absolument besoin de banques yves de
glace donc là cette maman ours
elle a ses deux petits et c'est déjà
fait beaucoup de petits et il ya
d'autres photos que je n'ai pas montré
parce que à cette maman ours
c'est au mois de juin elle est quand
même très très maigre et à des grosses
difficultés à nourrir ses petits
donc c'est vrai que la photo est un peu
idyllique mais derrière il ya quand même
un gros problème de où c'est aussi un
moyen de dénoncer le dénoncez pas
dénoncer d'informer d'informer il arrive
sur ce qu'elles vont dénoncer tout le
monde sait que le réchauffement
climatique actuel la pose de gros
problèmes en particulier en arctique où
la fonte des glaces est quand même très
très rapide on était en arctique mais
vous allez aussi dans des pays très
chaud on va avoir une deuxième photo ces
joutes seront pas là a été prise au
kenya c'est un rhinocéros et puis je
suis pareil si vous pouvez m'en parle un
petit mais ferait de ce héros ça a été
pris au kenya dans le masaï mara
il était quoi 17h 18h coucher du soleil
avec un orage conviendra en afrique
souvent donc des belles lumières et puis
donc la mise au point est très très
compliqué parce que là le jour où il
fait un peu n'importe quoi donc c'est
vraiment manuel pour arriver à capter
l'effet de la pluie du contre jour du
soleil
et puis voilà cette image elle a
beaucoup plu elle a très bien fonctionné
mais vous parlez voilà la cuisine pour
des questions climatiques comment on
fait pour tout ce qui est matériel
alors là au kenya on est on est on est
en 4 4 donc on est couvert
il ya en afrique l'a fait ça se faire
l'afrique à pied mais c'est d'une autre
démarche
là on est abritée quand même et vous
avez des projets chez sur alors les
projets futurs actuellement je travaille
ça fait la 4e' part d'un troisième fois
que je suis parti en arctique et j'y
retourne là au mois de mars le 23 mars
pour la période hivernale
donc ça fait la quête ça sera la
quatrième fois donc j'ai fait le
svalbard sur les quatre saisons au mois
d'août au mois de juin ou en septembre
et au mois de mars
je suis en train de préparer une
exposition et puis un livre qui est en
préparation ou vous sent très amoureux
de la nature lui la nature c'est
vraiment un endroit où je me sens
vraiment très très bien être claude le
travail de philippe bol c'est inspirant
ses formateurs pour un amateur
je pense que c'est formateur s'ils
voulaient pis vous avez vu nous a parlé
de ce qu'il aime d'état dire qu'elle
protéger la nature
je crois que six blessés c'est ça qui
m'a touché ciblés dans cette dans sa
démarche ce que je connais quand même
philippe depuis quelques temps
donc c'est pour ça que c'est vrai j'ai
pensé que ça pouvait être un invité
intéressant pour l'été les
téléspectateurs de tv fil 78 et que ça
peut donner des idées aux gens s'ils
voulaient que pour qu'il puisse regarder
ce travail cette photo cette
photographie animalière autres manquent
si vous voulez en cliquant en faisant
alors il est vrai qu'on peut faire de
très belles choses avec son chat avec
son chien mais ciblé ce sont des animaux
domestiques là philippe nous montre
quand même la diversité vous avez vu
vous tout à l'heure dans le film en 2d
cran cette espèce d'oiseau quitterait
une espèce qui est très localisée sur le
caine en ouganda je crois avec frais
l'oiseau avec sabots et ce qui est
intéressant moi quand il m'a montré ces
images c'est d'aller regarder ciblé
c'est quoi ce trois heures je n'avais
jamais vu et de découvrir cible et ça
permet aussi de découvrir quelque chose
et je crois que nous avons déjà fait des
expositions ciblées au centre de saint
quentin en yvelines peut-être qu'on
refera parce que mes que les enfants
viennent voir pour qu'il puisse
s'imprégner ciblées de ce qu'est la
nature et comment il voulait voilà c'est
ça merci sud et bolt est venu nous
présenter votre travail
claude on vous retrouve toujours les
photos on peut toujours en bas alors je
vous rappelle le thème qui est l auto
portrait alors je dis bien c'est pas
faire d selphy c'est de faire un auto
portrait et nous avons reçu quand même
de très belles choses déjà et on en
attend encore le dépôt et jusqu'au 7
mars et le
le résultat du concours sera fait donc
le 11 mars sur ce plateau ils nous
remettront un petit cadeau donc la
personne pourra gagner si nous avons le
plaisir de la recevoir sur son plateau
merci à tous les deux n'hésitez pas à
envoyer vos photos on reste dans le
thème de la photographie puisque
jusqu'au 19 mars elle la mezzanine de
l'hôtel deviennent de guyancourt expose
le travail de barbara pèlerins
l'artiste présente des portraits
grandeur nature de guillon courtoise
patrick jacques de dixmude et sephora
dahmani une impression d'icônes rendu
par un contraste clair obscur appuyer un
travail de la lumière à la manière des
peintres espagnol du xviie siècle
des clichés de plain-pied pris dans
l'intimité pour rendre compte de huit
portraits
huit parcours de vie issue du métissage
culturel ce sont les étrangers
étrangères de barbara pèlerins la photo
de plain pied
c'est l'occasion de
de faire du portrait afin de faire un
portrait un peu complet bien delà de la
tête aux pieds en prenant en compte le
vêtement la façon dont les femmes sont
habillées les pieds qui sont assez
présents dans la composition les objets
qui sont vent sont posés sur le sol
c'est un cadrage qui est un véritable
parti pris à la fois parce que c'est un
rappel à la picturalité et et en même
temps parce que l'identité c'est pas
simplement le visage un travail
manifeste de la richesse de la diversité
culturelle auquel est attaché barbara
pèlerins artiste engagé l'ancien élève
de l'école boulle et de l'école
nationale de la photographie à arles
prolonge ses recherches dans ses
ateliers du bel air à montreuil sur le
thème de la binationalité une passion
qu'elle partage également avec ses
élèves du conservatoire des arts de
montigny le bretonneux
ce qui me plaît c'est que c'est une
histoire laissant de chaque femme
du coup qui devient un patrimoine parce
que ces fameux vivent pour la plupart du
temps depuis longtemps en france elles
ont eu des enfants en france et elles
ont une histoire qui est passionnante
parce que justement il ya eu le voyage
pourquoi elles ont quitté leur pays
d'origine
l'arrivée en france et
comment
on se considère à la fois française et
en même temps d'un pays étranger
l'exposition étrange étrangères a été
commandée par la ville de guyancourt
dans le cadre de la journée de la femme
elle est présentée à la mezzanine de
l'hôtel de ville de guyancourt jusqu'au
19 mars avec un vernissage prévu le 10
mars prochain et vous en avez maintenant
l'habitude chaque semaine les libraires
du pavé du canal vous propose une idée
lecture cette semaine le coup de coeur
de stéphanie férial et pour l'autre
joseph de kéthévane davrichewy on les
écoute
alors je vous présente le nouveau roman
de kéthévane davrichewy l'autre joseph
aux éditions sabine wespieser pour
lequel j'ai vraiment eu un gros coup de
coeur en fait elle raconte l'histoire de
son arrière grand père joseph davrichewy
qu'est né à la fin du 19e siècle en
géorgie dans le même village et quelques
années après à joseph beaucoup plus
connu celui là qui sera joseph staline
donc elle raconte en fait l'histoire
dans une géorgie encore très rurale de
ces deux joseph qui vont avoir une vie
quand même assez parallèle dans une
effectivement géorgie et rural également
sous la coupe d'un d'un voisin quand
même assez omniprésent qui est la russie
d'accord et elle raconte notamment
comment va naître leur leurs convictions
politiques leur ferveur surtout
révolutionnaire est ce qu'ils vont
devenir tous les deux donc on connaît ce
que enfin ce qui va arriver
effectivement à joseph staline un petit
peu moins finement pour son
arrière-grand-père qui en soi va être un
vrai pas avoir une vie de vrai
personnage de roman il va être espion il
va il va compter
être parent faire partie des premiers
pilotes de la première guerre mondiale
voilà donc c'est un livre absolument
passionnant qui entremêle vie à la
petite et la grande histoire assez sobre
comme écriture assez assez efficace je
dirais que c'est effectivement assez
court passionnant aussi sur l'héritage
familial parce qu'en fait elle mène à la
fois une enquête sur cet arrière grand
père qui est un personnage en fait
plutôt trouble dans sa famille elle vous
ne savez pas très bien où il ya beaucoup
de choses qu'on ne connaissait pas de
lui même si lui même avait écrit un
livre sur son enfance et qu'il avait
côtoyé avec citadine voilà un superbe
roman moi j'ai eu vraiment un bon coup
de coeur passionnant on apprend beaucoup
de choses
voilà donc l'autre joseph de kéthévane
davrichewy et pour terminer cette ut
week-end de rendez vous la serre aux
papillons à la queue-lez-yvelines a
rouvert ses portes le 20 février dernier
vous pouvez donc découvrir ou
redécouvrir les centaines de papillons
qui vivent les horaires et tarifs sont à
retrouver sur le site internet
et pour les amateurs de football
américain direction le complexe sportif
europe d'elancourt ce samedi les
templiers affrontent les dauphins de
nice voilà le 7 oui qu'elle est terminée
je vous remercie de nous avoir suivis je
vous retrouve la semaine prochaine pour
encore plus d'idées loisirs et sorties
et d'ici là passez un très bon week-end